[Musique]
ils n'étaient pas nombreux mais ils ont
donné de la voix les militants du parti
animalistes se sont rendus ce week end
aux abords du salon international de la
chasse dans les yvelines quelques jours
après la diffusion sur les réseaux de la
mise à mort d'un cerf aux abois à les
pieux en pleine rue à cros rouvre les
manifestants voulaient rappeler l'agonie
et la souffrance entraîné par une
pratique qu'ils jugent barbares civile
logique complètement incompréhensible
voilà pour ça je veux qu'on arrête de
tuer des animaux pour à plaisir qu'elle
me dise pas que c'est pour la nourriture
c'est complètement fou comme le disait
lamartine on n'a pas de coeur on a peint
en a pas un pour les humains et un pour
les animaux on en a on en a pas et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui d'une manière
générale d'ailleurs je trouve que la
société pousse les gens en fait à ne
plus avoir d'émotions de leur côté les
chasseurs souhaité faire preuve de
pédagogie pour expliquer leurs pratiques
si une pratique qui doit continuer qui
doit être raisonnée mais qui doit
continuer c'est une tradition ancestrale
qu'il faut préserver cette mobilisation
intervenait à moins de deux semaines de
l'élection présidentielle et si le parti
animalistes n'a pas réussi à recueillir
le nombre nécessaire de parrainage pour
y participer il annonce d'ores et déjà
être en mesure de présenter quelques 400
candidats lors des législatives